vamos a practicar el calcular y comparar
razones la tienda de mascotas tiene tres
tanques de peces cada uno contiene
diferente volumen de agua y distinta
cantidad de peces el tanque a tiene
cinco peces y un volumen en litros de 40
40 litros
el tanque bet tiene 12 peces y 100
litros y el tanque se tiene 23 peces y
180 litros ordena los tanques por
volumen por pez de menor a mayor
entonces veamos el volumen por mes
el volumen dividido entre el pez volumen
por pez así que para el tanque a va a
ser 40 litros entre cinco peces 40
litros por cada 5 veces y veamos 40
entre 5 y 8 así que tenemos 8 litros por
pez
esta es la razón de agregar agua por
cada pez en este tanque en el tanque a
en el tanque ve tenemos 100 litros entre
12 peces
a cuánto va a ser igual esto bueno 12
caben 108 veces y nos quedan 8 por 296
esto va a ser 8 y 4 12 a 2 y 8 enteros
un tercio litros por pez
y todo lo que hice fue convertir esta
fracción impropia 100 entre 12 en un
número mixto y simplifique la fracción
12 caben 100 8 veces y queda un residuo
de 44 entre 12 que es lo mismo que un
tercio
y finalmente en el tanque se tengo 180
litros
entre 23 veces esto que va a ser igual
bueno 23 cabe en 187 veces pero vamos a
calcularlo con más exactitud 20 que
divide a 180 esto es menor que nueve
veces 18 por esto no se pasa va a ser 7
7 por 13 21 llevamos 27 por dos es 14
más dos que llevamos es 16 161 restamos
180 menos 161 y nos da 19 así que es 7
con un residuo de 19 entre 23 7 y 19
sobre 23
litros por pez
ahora tenemos que ordenar los tanques
por volumen por pez de menor a mayor el
tanque es el que tiene mayor cantidad de
volumen por pez tiene ocho y un tercio
litros por pez será en primer lugar
luego el tanque está en segundo lugar y
el tanque se está en tercer lugar ops
pero nos están pidiendo que vayan de
menor a mayor así que esto no va así lo
quitamos
el tanque se es el menos y el tanque b
es el mayor
así que ahora solo tenemos que
intercambiar este orden esta pantalla es
una copia de un ejercicio que está en el
portal de khan academy así que vamos a
ver el ejercicio real para resolverlo y
aquí ya puedo reordenar estos tanques
que es el menor que es el mayor sacamos
nuestra respuesta y es correcta